سنحاول عبر الكاميرا نقل ما يحدث من خلفي
هنا كما تشاهدون اولا سنحاول فقط اظهار ان
الاهالي تعتمد على الاخشاب وما يجمعونه من
الاماكن هنا للتدفئه هناك عشرات العوائل
نشاهدها في هذه الجبال تقوم بالتدفئه على
النار التي تشعرها مما تجمعه من الارض
تماما الاحتياجات بالدرجه الاولى مواد
التدفئه ثم ملابس الاطفال الشتويه شاهدنا
كل الاطفال
بالبيجامات وملابس النوم فبالتالي هناك
نقص كبير في ملابس التدفئه والدفء لهذه
العوائل التي فضلت البقاء بالقرب من
منازلها
بانتظار اي خبر عن ذويهم المفقودين تحت
هذه الانقاذ هذه القيام ايضا تحتاج الى
مطابخ ميدانيه عاجله لتقديم الغذاء لها
لانها لا تملك اي امكانيات ربما لصناعه
الطعام وغيره وايضا لا تملك ايه نقود كل
الاهالي فقدت امكانياتها الماديه وغيرها
داخل منازلها على الشق الاخر تحتاج هذه
الاهالي كما ذكرت السلات الاغاثيه العاجله
وايضا مواد
يعني الخيام وغيرها في المرحله اللاحقه
ممكن كما اكدت المنظمات الانسانيه انها
تحتاج لبناء او تقديم الكتل الاسمنتيه
والشقق العاجله ربما لتقديمها من فقد
منزله بشكل كامل اتحدث عن اكثر من 20 الف
عائله هي الان مهجره منهم من تضرر منزله
بشكل كامل على الانقاض ومنهم من تضرر بشكل
جزئي لكن لن تعود هذه الاهالي الى منازلها
وهناك معلومه مهمه من نتحدث عنهم اليوم هم
اصلا نازحون لمرات عديده بفعل تهجيرهم من
قراهم ومنازلهم سابقا والقصف